comment allez vous moi ça va j'ai pu que
j'ai réussi à faire ce mouvement des
amis on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
seconde et dernière partie du phone game
que benjamin avait fait la première
partie manitoba ont fait kiffer la
deuxième ça va être tout aussi cool
j'espère on s'est évanouie après un
maximum d'épreuves difficiles et nous
avons ce poème dans cette barque
voilà alors une cassette infos que j'ai
chopé la cassette de gens affectés faut
pas que je touche l'eau interdit
d'accord et mais j'adore dans la vraie
vie j'adore faire ce jeu à la vraie vie
j'adore faire ce jeu des cailloux là je
pense que ben aussi sur ce qu'il a fait
une game ok y'a pas de sel si je perds
là on chiale l'oise tout ce qui se passe
à bordeaux
tdanse réduit et nous la met dans le cul
la benne indirects blasquez et moi je
suis fière mais quand je roule bien
d'ailleurs quand georges pas aussi je
vous le dit ajoutant julliard qu'est ce
que vous faites encore sur matches nuls
1-1 gentillesse
allez on va dire un mot gentil à chaque
mois ces supplices et mieux soyeux aux
agréables
l'ase à l'aise
mais
yes it is et padilha dans une petite
ferme et laverdure je vais choper cette
caste jeudi mécano mais là je vais
vraiment là moi j'en ai marre qu'à cette
[ __ ] je vais la chaux pcc la maison
d'un fan fou que va avoir des abonnés
que jeune dame un pokemon co la chasse
d'un expert 300 villas bonne et les mini
vieille vidéo c'est rigolo ils ont
divisé la maison c'est quand je
l'appelais dans la première vidéo c'est
regarder sur les screen il a mis le
pouce bleus à chaque fois ben je laime
souviens toi du chemin parcouru
jusqu'ici à ok je dois les classer par
ordre chronologique c'est bien joué je
pense que c'est ça donc logiquement la
première c300 est devenue la deuxième
c'est cochonnailles la troisième c'est
les 5 ans est-ce que ça c'était avant
pokémon à tanger regarde elle daté 9
mois et deux semaines pokémon elle daté
de juin
pokémon c'est avant je me connais bien
c'est bien ça c'est oui c'est bien ça
c'est l'avantagé d'avoir un maximum des
go du coup tu sais bien ce que tu as
fais comme tu l'as fait c'est très bien
[ __ ] faut qu'il faut que je renverse
aucune bouteille à la mecque mission
commando là
[Musique]
non je dis bien qu'absent tortue est
accolée de merde c'est dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
via son marché j'ai pas envie de t&d de
[ __ ] tu me pattes les couilles au
stylet cette action
il ya beaucoup de monde à moi
c'est chaud [ __ ] de près tout récents
tels quels étaient ses lois mais attends
rien de tout sur moi
oh [ __ ] ça le faire oh ça va le faire
quand je suis arrivé j'ai reçu c'est
bien ça c'est fait il rendait puta tu
peux me tester maintenant ouais ouais
ouais tranquille
je te remercie mon pote ok alors grandin
on apprend des choses à ok alors votre
base à mixait mais il faut qu'on trouve
le butin ordi alès partition [ __ ] je
crois qu'il en est dans la ligne droite
du jeu mais qui va pouvoir retrouver
jumbo se faire plaisir
il m'a fait super peur mais [ __ ] on
dirait une qui a fait la morale boys
très bizarre ok on est de retour au tout
début du game pour tous vous le redis la
la
allez finir la lampe aller carrément
fâché je t'avais regard là quoi alors
qu'est ce qu'un ces pièces et le bureau
ont 10 heures dr lengagne benjamin ok je
peux aimer le pc à faux le brancher au
plat ok modes passent les mecs aiment
ces entrées journal de bord nous n'avons
plus aucun animal à disposition
gouvernement n'a apparemment pas le
temps d'attendre le vaccin étaient
implantées dans 24 sujets humains à je
dois me concentrer sur leur guérison
mais je dois penser avoir un sujet
réussi incorrectement vaccin aujourd'hui
un chat est tombé de la trappe je vais
essayer de tester le vaccin dessus c'est
john connor n'était ce pas sur dieu pour
tous mes échantillons ont été volés
jumbo a disparu douze personnes ont été
retrouvées étranglées gens accusent une
langue qu'est ce qui se passe ici je l'
ai vu la lampe
elle a étranglé un de mes collègues
devant mes yeux [ __ ] us army a mis la
main sur squeeze ils savent que jumbo
est l'antidote ils l'obtiennent jamais
le monde ne serait guéri ils vont servir
d'une machine à vecteur mémorielle
programmé pour retrouver le ch a étudié
squeeze en long et en large donc ça
c'est le premier chapitre c'est ce qui
se passait il retrouvera djabou et
sauvera le monde
enfin s'il en est capable ceci est mon
dernier message d'adieu [ __ ] à ça a
pété il va exploser à savon je suis
passé aux caisses à sa femme et j'ai eu
peur
ok par la non ok il faut juste un truc
d'essence et un engrenage
ok poteau t'inquiète pas je vais trouver
lui donner sens à l'engrenage au bst l
on voit ces spirales put toi si tu en
vises et cette perte saloperie
saloperie de l'homme de merde allez vite
un engrenage et un truc d'essence yes ça
c'est fait ok maintenant pukha non loin
la journée bon là c'est ça je lai [ __ ]
on sent des sorties sont fait un peu la
benz incroyable maires différents
leviers aussi voilà là ils sont nombreux
jeunes et jolies aux pièces enfin botter
le cul de cette [ __ ] de l'amp et en
finir une bonne fois pour toutes
alors allez bon allez je te sors mon
pote se termine est finie la souffrance
de jouer à ce jour agents ok on y va
djemba djemba mon chat c'est fini oh mon
dieu
eh ben ce ne fut pas de tout repos cette
histoire un mois passent me tout j'en ai
un peu chier non pas suite aux mecs
benjamin versé beaucoup mon gars en fait
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais faire un jeu comme ça c'est
vraiment beaucoup de temps à investir on
va là plus on va le remercie et vous la
dire que c'était génial pour iphone
blagues ratées je vais le frank et wave
yeux je suis encore bloqués c'est faux
j'ai réussi j'ai terminé et ouais je
sais je t'ai pas manquer en live bon mec
bravo c'est ouf c'est ouf a vraiment un
mec c'est ça j'ai tourné pendant deux
heures parce que je suis nul en prenant
en compte que je suis très nul
when i can bah oui ben j'ai kiffé voilà
un gros bravo les gens te disent bravo
je les entends comme ça à travers la
caméra et puis mc merci beaucoup et puis
voilà je sais pas quand on pourra
peut-être un autre jeu où j'en sais rien
tiens regarde ou chaoping et jeté plus
pis depuis plusieurs mois hockey
j'espère que je vous aura fait kiffer
aussi qui vous ont rappelé les délires
de 2014 2015 la période des questions de
temps avec ses terrasses est vraiment là
où il y avait la langue jumbo dans
toutes les vidéos a pas se mentir ça a
bien changé depuis mais c'est marrant de
voir ce qu'il a fait avec ces personnes
on avait créé à l'époque c'était rigolo
encore noirmont ben merci à vous d'avoir
regardé la vidéo je vous dis à bientôt
dans une prochaine
à bientôt
[Musique]